Traductor: Rocío Gutiérrez Muñoz de la Torre
Revisor: Miguel Cisneros-Franco
[Música]
¿Cuántas veces puedes
doblar un trozo de papel?
Supón que tuvieras
un trozo de papel muy fino,
como el que se suele usar en la Biblia.
En realidad, parece un trozo de seda.
Para matizar esta idea,
digamos que el papel tiene
una milésima de centímetro de grosor.
Que es 10 elevado a
menos 3 centímetros,
que es igual que 0,001 centímetros.
Supongamos también que tienes
un trozo de papel muy grande,
como la página de un periódico.
Ahora empezamos
a doblarlo por la mitad.
¿Cuántas veces crees
que se puede doblar así?
Otra pregunta:
Si pudieras doblar un papel
todas las veces que quisieras,
digamos 30 veces, ¿qué grosor
crees que tendría ese papel?
Antes de que sigamos,
te animo a que pienses de verdad
una posible respuesta a la pregunta.
Vale. Tras doblar una vez el papel,
Tiene dos milésimas
de centímetro de grosor.
Si volvemos a doblarlo por la mitad,
el papel tendrá
cuatro milésimas de centímetro.
Con cada pliegue que hacemos,
el papel dobla su grosor.
Y si seguimos
doblándolo una y otra vez,
siempre por la mitad, nos enfrentaremos
a la siguiente situación
tras 10 pliegues.
Dos elevado a diez,
es decir, que multiplicas
dos por sí mismo diez veces,
es mil y 24 milésimas de centímetro,
que es poco más de un centímetro.
Supón que seguimos
doblando el papel por la mitad.
¿Qué ocurrirá?
Si lo doblamos 17 veces,
obtendremos un grosor
de dos elevado a 17,
que son 131 centímetros,
y eso es poco más de un metro.
Si pudiéramos doblarlo 25 veces,
obtendríamos dos elevado a 25,
que son 33,554 centímetros,
algo más de 335 metros.
El papel sería casi tan alto
como el Empire State.
Vale la pena parar
y reflexionar un momento.
Al doblar un papel por la mitad, incluso
uno tan fino como el de la Biblia,
25 veces, obtendríamos un papel
de unos 400 metros.
¿Qué aprendemos?
Este tipo de crecimiento
se llama crecimiento exponencial,
y como puedes ver,
tan solo con doblar un papel
podemos llegar muy lejos y muy rápido.
En resumen, si doblamos
un papel 25 veces,
el grosor es de unos 100 metros.
Con 30 veces, el grosor
sobrepasa los 10 kilómetros,
que es la altura media
a la que vuelan los aviones.
Con 40 veces, el grosor
son unos 11.000 kilómetros,
o la órbita media de un satélite GPS.
Con 48 veces, el grosor sobrepasa
el millón y medio de kilómetros.
Ahora, si crees que la distancia
entre la Tierra y la Luna
es menor a 400.000 kilómetros,
entonces, cogiendo
un trozo de papel de la Biblia
y doblándolo 45 veces,
se puede llegar a la luna
Y si lo doblamos una vez más,
podemos volver a la Tierra.
Clase impartida por: Adrian Paenza
Narración: Adrian Paenza
Animación: TED-ED Team